vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le projet de
nouvelle constitution sera soumis à
référendum le 25 juillet elle a été
dévoilée en tunisie sucre sans surprise
caixa est dit propose une vision
radicalement différente du système
parlementaire actuelle il renforce les
pouvoirs du chef de
la cédéao va t'elle lever les sanctions
qui pèsent sur le mali les dirigeants
vont se réunir ce dimanche à accra en
attendant on vous propose un portage
abidjan pour y mesurer l'impact des
sanctions sur la diaspora malienne
la première du pays et vous verrez que
les conséquences sont nombreuses
ce soir on a reçu une légende de la
musique il a fait danser des générations
partout sur le continent et dans le
monde un ambassadeur du reggae en
afrique alpha blondy était dans le
journal de l'afrique et les lunes
présenter son nouvel album eternity
toujours engagé une mystique extraits à
suivre
le président tunisien a publié un projet
de constitution qui sera soumis à
référendum le 25 juillet de vastes
pouvoirs ils sont accordés au chef de
l'état une vision radicalement
différente du système parlementaire en
place kacey propose en somme de graver
dans la loi sa propre gestion du pays
depuis qu'il s'est arrogé les pleins
pouvoirs l'année dernière la
correspondance à tunis de lilia blesse
c'est une constitution qui à peine
publiées suicide déjà de nombreux débats
d'une part parce qu'elle met fin au
système politique qui a prévalu en
tunisie depuis dix ans après la
révolution et puis aussi parce qu'elle
consacre une hyperprésidentialisation
des pouvoirs avec beaucoup de
prérogatives accordées au président de
la république et enfin elle impose une
autre vision de l'identité de l'état
tunisien selon deux experts à qui nous
avons pu parler c'est plutôt une
constitution qui s'éloigne de la de la
démocratie tunisienne on voit une
certaine centralisation du du durant du
président une prise présidentialisation
du système un président au dessus de
toutes les
la redevabilité disons il n'est pas
redevable devant aucune autre structure
les articles 5 6 et 7 stipule que les
plus de préambule stipule que la tunisie
est une partie de la oumma islamique que
l'état
que l'état uniquement oeuvre à la
concrétisation des finalités du lsa gelé
d'amp l'état-nation tunisien a été trois
fois dilué que reste-t-il de
l'état-nation tunisien ce qui est pour
l'état civil il n'y a aucune notion du
caractère civil de l'état contrairement
à l'article 2 de la précédente
constitution russe qui stipulait que la
tunisie est un état civil qui repose sur
le site orienté ce texte doit être à
présent explique et vulgariser au
tunisien en vue de la campagne pour le
référendum un référendum qui se tiendra
le 25 juillet certains partis politiques
ont déjà appelé à son boycott ou passe
au soudan où neuf personnes sont mortes
à khartoum a battu sur les tirs des
policiers pendant une manifestation ce
jeudi malgré les coupures d'internet et
la forte présence policière
des milliers de soudanais se mobilisent
appelant les généraux à quitter le
pouvoir immédiatement sophie lamothe
les mêmes slogans résonnent depuis huit
mois dans la capitale des foules énormes
se dirigent vers le palais royal dans le
centre de racht um
[Applaudissements]
à l'origine pacifique les manifestants
tombent sous les balles des policiers
neuf personnes dont un mineur sont tués
jeudi en octobre dernier le pays retombe
dans la violence après un putsch mené
par le général burhan qui renversent des
autorités transitionnelle depuis plus
d'une centaine de personnes ont été
tuées dans des manifestations pro
démocratie mais la résistance ne faiblit
pas
le peuple doit compter sur lui même
maintenant et il ne reculera jamais tant
que ses objectifs ne seront pas atteints
il n'y a aucun peuple dans l'histoire du
monde qui ait été vaincue et le peuple
soudanais aura la victoire sur les
généraux
il reste huit mois au pays pour trouver
un consensus sur la constitution et
organiser des élections démocratiques
l'onu et l'union africaine maintiennent
la pression sur le régime militaire en
vain pour l'instant
mais une seule ma principale
préoccupation est que la fin de la
période de transition approche à grands
pas lier plus mais les progrès dans la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord de paix ont
été longs avec seulement huit mois
restants les chances de mettre en place
des changements sur la devise
une crise politique qui aggrave la
situation économique du pays avec près
de neuf millions de personnes qui
pourraient connaître une fin extrême
cette année d'après le programme
alimentaire mondial
allez on passe au reste de l'actualité
africaine en bref et en images le
burundi célèbre en ce 1er juillet le 60e
anniversaire de son indépendance depuis
cette date le pays n'a pas connu 15 ans
continue de stabilité politique des
pouvoirs militaires se sont succédé des
massacres ethniques à grande échelle ont
déchiré le tissu social l'économie est
exsangue et certains observateurs
craignent que le folklore de cette fête
permettent au pouvoir de se réclamer les
héros de l'indépendance
le groupe français castel visait à paris
par une enquête pour crimes contre
l'humanité en centrafrique
le géant français est accusé dans un
rapport sorti en août 2000 21 d'avoir
via sa filiale locale négocier avec le
groupe armé upc accusé de multiples
exactions dans le pays les ong seraient
juste cette avancée de son côté castel a
décidé de rester sobre et prend acte de
la décision et assure une coopération
pleine et entière avec la justice
un nouvel accord sur l'immigration signé
par le royaume uni après le rwanda les
britanniques ont signé avec le nigeria
un partenariat de lutte contre
l'immigration qualifiée d'historique cet
accord devrait permettre selon les
signataires de favoriser des intérêts
économiques bilatéraux partager
ce dimanche les dirigeants de la cedeao
vont se réunir à accra pour décider sur
la levée des sanctions à l'encontre du
mali des sanctions qui pénalise les
habitants du pays comme ceux de la
diaspora c'est le cas des habitants en
côte d'ivoire très nombreux dans le pays
il espère retrouver une vie normale car
depuis janvier les conséquences sont
nombreuses reportage danyang ferjani et
samuel bernés
à abidjan c'est ici que l'on vient
acheter son mouton en raison des
sanctions de la cedeao envers le mali la
plupart des bêtes venait du burkina faso
du niger mais depuis le 27 juin
l'embargo sur les têtes de bétail
malienne a été levée l'objectif
faciliter l'acheminement de ces moutons
en vue de la fête musulmane de tabaski
une chance pour ce vendeur membres de la
communauté malienne
mais si mal et fermés ça diminue si
longtemps ne vient pas là ne manquez pas
les killers aussi même chose ça les fait
se faire hélas tous les goûts mais
dimaga et les réponses est très beau
mais tous les secteurs n'ont pas cette
chance les marchands de textile maliens
doivent se passer des produits issus de
leur propre pays des textiles portant
prisé de la clientèle ivoiriennes
qu'elles s'acquittent tourmalet à
l'étoile du mal et aussi
la diaspora malienne en côte d'ivoire
compte 6 millions de membres qui
travaillent majoritairement dans le
secteur du commerce les difficultés
concernent aussi le quotidien à cause
des sanctions nombreuses sont les
familles de maliens séparer obligations
familiales mariages ou funérailles sont
devenus impossibles à honorer
aujourd'hui
je pleure pas singles au moment où tu
veux
la sanction
à la veille du sommet de la cedeao qui
doit se prononcer sur une éventuelle
levée des sanctions avec le mali les
maliens d'abidjan espère que les
différentes parties trouveront un accord
il est né en côte d'ivoire et à presque
70 ans et il a fait danser au rythme du
reggae des générations d'africains il
chante en français en dioula et en
anglais son aura et son talent ont fait
de lui une légende vivante et il est
venu présenter son dix neuvième album
eternity on a demandé à alpha blondy
surtout de nous parler de sa rencontre
avec le reggae
les premières chansons que j'ai écouté
c'est un livre et un film inspiré comme
ça à la radio ok et puis la grosse
découverte c'est quand je suis à new
york à central park et puis un concert
ailleurs hfa music festival à l'époque
on va voir et puis on découvre tu
comprends burning spear ok cette voix
qui glorifie l'afrique qui dénonce l'
esclavage dure même brice leverdez
hockey et plus qui glorifie l'afrique
vous voyez un peu vous quittez votre
afrique et plus vous venez à new york et
puis vous tomber sur des gens qui n'ont
pas oublié l'afrique qui glorifie
l'afrique ça vous met du baume au coeur
et en plus moi qui avait des choses à
dire ok cette musique avait une épine
dorsale spirituel dieu ok et moi je ne
peux pas dissocier l'être humain de dieu
ok dans le bonheur comme dans le malheur
donc voilà pourquoi leur gamme a séduit
et d'ailleurs le spirituel dieu le
mystique est très présent dans ce nouvel
album eternity que vous sortez votre 19e
album je compose à présent qu'on écoute
un extrait on a choisi au hasard mais
pas si hazard que ça un extrait avec
sidiki diabaté on l'écouté on en parle
du set après toi
ça
elle est pas marqué restant à payer
[Applaudissements]
on a entendu un extrait justement l'a
écrit avec sidiki diabaté
je me demander comment est ce que vous
aviez concocté cet album cette dix
neuvième album justement j'ai dit
toujours engagé
mystique quand même et spirituel au 6e
sur les thèmes que chivu qui vous sont
chers depuis longtemps j'ai travaillé à
la maison surtout sur deux tableaux nous
on travaille à la maison on envoyait les
éléments les fichiers à nos musiciens
mais musiciens qui sont à paris il
travaille dans leur home studio et que
nous le renvoyer à vision donc c'est
comme ça qu'on a travaillé bon après
tout le temps pour une fois on a eu deux
ans de vacances hockey khl a été
justement votre votre but dans la
création de c est ce qu il ya eu une
volonté d'inclure particulièrement les
jeunes je vous promets que c'est eux qui
viennent à vous c'est dieu qui les a
guidés vers moi parce que stone brouille
étaient intervenus pour la promotion de
son nouvel album à la radio alpha blondy
et puis il à dire mon fils abdel je veux
rencontrer papa alpha blondy longtemps
studio louise labelle fallu venir et
puis il arrive et tombe sur on travaille
sur la chanson love parle et il a aimé
je vous ai déjà dit ce que je peux faire
quelque chose de divin open mic l'asie
et il est rentré la fracasser quoi tu
vois là avant lui il y avait mon fils
sidiki diabaté qui aussi un jour vous
dire bonjour et puis d'entrer en studio
et puis je le fais écouter trois
chansons et des trois chansons il a aimé
et
puis après je vais faire ça ouais donc
ça à vue dont il a une si belle voix est
puissante du l'art du bonsaï a admis qu
ok j'ai beaucoup aimé ça ça vous touche
force et oui et ne sont pas plus tard
deux mois plus tard lui aussi je les
appelais vous venez faire justement la
couronne en battant sans immigrés oui il
est venu il a écouté
ce que j'ai fait avec celui qui et puis
là lui l'a fait la cour à céder qui n'a
pas fait la cour à dans la série je ne
sais pas vraiment alpha blondy c'est le
patron
c'est la fin de ce jour ma de l'afrique
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis
rester avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]